there is another potential candidate in
the race no I'm not talking about Bobby
Kennedy no I'm not talking about
Marianne Williamson
I'm talking about
old father time himself the man who has
run for office consistently since what
1972.
just like Joe Biden actually same same
year Biden got elected I'm talking about
Bernie Sanders
the president has a right to be very
proud of many of the accomplishments
that we've achieved in the last three
years unemployment very very low we
brought inflation down we're investing
in clean energy we're rebuilding our
infrastructure we have made real
progress in a number of areas but
the reality is that today
sixty percent of our people living
paycheck to paycheck we have massive
levels of income and wealth inequality
three people or more wealth in the
bottom half of America our Health Care
system is a total disaster 85 million
people uninsured uninsured underinsured
while the insurance companies make huge
profits the cost of pharmaceutical drugs
prescription drugs Sky hype
Bernie Sanders traveling up to New
Hampshire
delivering a speech called the agenda
America needs Bernie Sanders
has been running for office since 1972.
is it really so crazy to think he might
run again
why not
the two leading candidates okay the
leading candidate for each party right
now is rather elderly a gentleman of a
certain age and Bernie's been running
his own whole life consistently since
1972.
he ran for nine years for starting in
1972 he didn't even get elected to
anything until 1981 he becomes mayor of
Burlington 10 years later elected to
congress 15 16 years later he gets
elected to the Senate runs for president
the last two times why wouldn't he run
now plus
in a way the wind is at Bernie's back
because he was one of the early populist
candidates don't forget Bernie for all
of his wickedness and from racing
socialism which is an evil ideology and
completely unacceptable for any a
conservative or Christian certainly to
to embrace
Bernie was not just a lockstep Democrat
Bernie was not his anti-gun as most
Democrats but he changed a little bit in
the presidential campaigns but he wasn't
his anti-gun because he's from Vermont
and he was pretty strongly
anti-immigration
because Bernie is an old school economic
populist and and he recognizes that that
mass migration is is a scam it's a scam
by the left to increase their voter
numbers but it's a scam by the business
right the Chamber of Commerce type right
to lower wages for the working class so
Bernie being a working class fighter at
least in his own mind he was he was
opposed to immigration but he's kind of
been dethroned as a populist he made
populism his whole career and then Trump
came in and ate his lunch and now in the
Democrat Party Bobby Kennedy is probably
taking that that lane as well right now
go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles whether
we love it or hate it AI is here to stay
and kill us all and to just take over
civilization and well
hopefully to help the economy a little
bit maybe to avoid the Terminator
situation AI is expected to create over
100 million new jobs globally some
include data scientists product
designers robotics engineers even tax
managers with AI skills zip recruiter is
the best way to use AI to help you find
people with those skills supercruiters
AI identifies candidates who are best
suited for all kinds of roles right now
you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
do you want the most qualified
candidates
ZipRecruiter uses its powerful AI not to
destroy the world but to help you and to
help your business and to build up our
economy go to ZipRecruiter right now
they let you easily invite candidates to
apply get the Leading Edge on hiring
with ZipRecruiter 4 out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to ziprecruiter.com
for free ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
faith in college education has
completely collapsed in the United
States
public opinion polls about 10 13 years
ago
all had the same story and the story was
Americans believe in college
86 percent of college graduates around
2010 2012.
so the college had been a good
investment
another survey said 74 of young adults
viewed college education as very
important a third one said 60 of
Americans in total across the board said
colleges and universities were having a
positive impact on the country
in 2009 this was right around the time I
went to college little I went to college
in 2008.
70 percent of high school graduates
went straight to college
seventy percent that was an all-time
high in American history
and this was heralded as a wonderful
thing
now the trend is totally reversed and I
think that that's a much better thing
now
the percentage of young adults who said
college degree is very important has
gone from 74 to 41 a third of Americans
say they have confidence in higher
education among Zoomers 45 almost half
of Zoomers say a high school diploma is
all you need to ensure Financial
Security
and
almost half of American parents say they
don't want their kid to go to college
a total collapse how did that happen
well what the Liberals will say is this
this is backsliding this is regressive
this is the consequence of the
anti-intellectual Trump era in which
Trump brazenly said that he loves the
uneducated we're just going to hell in a
handbasket uh no no I don't think that's
quite the story I think the story is
that you can't hide a fraud forever
even the best con artist in the world
can't hide his crimes forever
of eventually Bernie Madoff is going to
get caught and the colleges are Bernie
Madoff it's been a complete racket what
what these colleges and the apparatchics
in government who boosted these colleges
by underwriting all of the loans that
allowed the tuitions to Skyrocket what
they promised was that if you come here
if you send your kid here your kid is
going to turn out better
and the initial promise the real promise
of a liberal education in the good sense
of the word liberal is that you learn to
make sense of your freedom and you steep
yourself in the culture of your
civilization and you you learn how to
think about abstract things and then you
can go on and get job training and have
a good career then when that didn't
materialize the the pitch for college
became hey come here and you'll get a
good job which was never what university
education was about it was never about
job training at all but they realized
okay well we're obviously not teaching
our kids to think in an abstract way the
standards that the colleges have
absolutely created so okay well don't
worry you're at least going to get a job
this is a credential that you need to
get a good high paying job and then
that kind of cratered too
now kids go and and all the while by the
way the cost has gone up to now what a
quarter million dollars to get a
four-year college degree in some places
and what's the payoff
there is no payoff you don't get any
intellectual or spiritual payoff you
don't even get a financial payoff it's
just a big scam oh and by the way your
kids come out of college hating you
because the college spends four years
undoing everything that you spent 18
years trying to instill into your
children
and because of the way our economy works
now you probably didn't get a whole ton
of time to spend with your children
because it's very hard to raise a family
on one income so both parents now
usually have to work so the kids end up
getting raised by by daycare workers and
by public school teachers from the age
of it used to be five now it's really
from the age of three or even two I have
friends who have two-year-olds they say
I'm sending my kid to school now to at
the age of Two And so you've already got
such an uphill battle
and then the colleges come and finish it
off and the parents and the students are
saying enough what's the benefit for
this is the conservative consolation
which is
things are really bad and they might get
worse and they might get even worse than
that
but reality reasserts itself eventually
in the end it has to you can't it is not
possible to deny reality
forever
boy what a great clip that was huh now
up before you go make sure you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time